on this friday night
putting the brakes on spring break
airlines ground flights to popular sun
destinations
now is just not the time to be flying
and if you do leave the country
there's a price to pay glimmers of hope
in the vaccine world
the promising results from two more
candidates but canada's coveted vaccine
rollout hits yet
another snag plus a devastating fire in
toronto
this is one of the worst tragedies by
fire i've seen in my career
the chaotic scene and the lives lost and
an ambitious climate plan goes into top
gear
it's a watershed moment because it
indicates just how quickly things are
accelerating
the move by general motors and the drive
for other automakers to follow in this
carbon footprint
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
cooped up canadians in desperate need of
a march break abroad are being warned to
make other plans
the federal government is tightening
travel measures to help slow the spread
of kova 19 and its highly infectious
variants canada's main airlines are
suspending service to popular sun
destinations
effective sunday until april 30th
starting february 3rd
international flights can only land in
vancouver calgary toronto
and montreal and in the coming weeks
there will be a mandatory cova test
at the airport for people returning to
canada
that's in addition to the test required
before the flight
we know that just one case of the
variant that comes in
uh could cause significant challenges
and that's why
we need to take extra measures uh yes
it is extremely uh low the percentage of
cases that are traced back to
international travel
but it's not zero there are still major
questions about how the changes will
roll out but as david aiken reports
what is clear is the hefty price you'll
pay if you insist
on packing your bags it is the federal
government's
strongest action yet to deter
non-essential
international travel with the challenges
we currently face with covet 19
both here at home and abroad we all
agree
that now is just not the time to be
flying
to start flights bound for any
destination in the caribbean or mexico
are canceled effective sunday and if you
think florida or california
is your next option for sun well
consider this
the biden administration will soon enact
mandatory
14-day quarantines for anyone arriving
in the u.s
on non-essential travel air travelers to
canada
are already required to have a coveted
19 test
before getting on the plane within a few
weeks
they'll also have to take a pcr cover 19
test
as soon as they get off the plane in
canada travelers
will then have to wait for up to three
days at an approved
hotel for their test results at their
own expense which is expected to be more
than two thousand dollars
travelers with a negative test and a
government approved quarantine plan
can head home but will be subject to
enhanced monitoring and surveillance
while they quarantine for 14 days
travelers with a
positive test or those without a
quarantine plan
will do their two-week quarantine in a
secure
federal government facility so the basic
foundation
of our public health measures is the
14-day quarantine
no compensation for the airlines was
announced friday
despite pleas by the industry for
urgently needed help
the carriers have taken the steps that
they took today at the at the request of
the government for reasons the
government has outlined
uh and therefore those measures will be
implemented but
we are still very much in need of
sectoral support that's why
the conversations with these airlines
continue one final thing
the government gave early warning friday
that soon it's going to require
all travelers arriving at the land
border to have a clean
covet 19 test before crossing back
into canada robin david the majority of
cases are still connected to community
spread is this an effective way to stop
the spread of the virus
well as a matter of fact the most recent
data collected by the public health
agency of canada shows that
just 1.4 of all the coveted 19 cases
we've had
in this country are as a result of
international travel
now that said it is quite clear that
public health authorities right now are
very concerned
about these new variants of the virus
that are out there these new variants
are more infectious and they may be a
little more resistant to existing
vaccines
and that's definitely a motivating
factor for these new measures
robin and they are worrisome thank you
very much david aiken in ottawa ontario
premier doug ford announced his own
mandatory testing plan for international
arrivals at canada's busiest airport
starting monday anyone arriving at
pearson on an international flight
will have to take a kova 19 test and
those who refuse to take one will be
fined
750 dollars ford says mandatory testing
at land border crossings will also be
implemented
as soon as possible the premier says he
can't count on the federal plan so
ontario is forging ahead with its own it
looks like these new measures
won't be fully in place until a few
weeks from now
that's a few weeks too long that's why
today
our government is taking swift and
decisive action
we're releasing a six-point plan to stop
the spread of covet 19 variants
and in manitoba new travel restrictions
are now in place requiring
anyone who enters the province to
self-isolate for 14 days
the province is also strongly advising
individuals to go for two coveted tests
one immediately upon arrival and one
again at seven days
regardless of symptoms manitobans are
still allowed to leave but the
province's top doctor is recommending
against
any travel for non-essential reasons
so we asked manitobans to work together
with us let's
keep our numbers down let's keep the
variant out follow the spirit of the
orders
don't look for ways to to skirt the
orders
we need to stay diligent if we want to
continue our reopening plans manitoba
has not detected any variant cases but
says it is testing for them
regularly the province reported 152 new
coven 19 infections today
and three deaths in alberta health
measures will be eased for restaurants
indoor fitness and some children's
activities
effective february 8. in-person dining
will resume with a maximum of six people
per table
liquor service will end at 10 p.m as for
fitness only one-on-one training will be
permitted
at indoor fitness facilities it's part
of a new provincial framework which will
ease health measures based on the number
of coveted 19 hospitalizations for the
second time in less than a month
canada is dealing with a delay in the
delivery of vaccines
no doses of the pfizer biontec vaccine
arrived in the country this week
pfizer is shipping roughly 80 percent
fewer shots than it initially promised
over the next month
production had to stop at its
manufacturing plant in belgium to do
upgrades
and today the prime minister confirmed
moderna will only be shipping about
75 of its expected doses next week
there is some good news health canada is
reviewing the clinical trial data
for the astrazeneca shot and a decision
could be coming within days
and then there's johnson and johnson the
company says its vaccine
is more than 60 percent effective and
only requires one dose
the timing is key because of the
shortage of vital vaccines
here's crystal gomezing
one jab and done johnson johnson is the
first to come to the table with positive
clinical data for a covet 19 vaccine
that requires just a single dose
it either stops you from getting covered
or it helps you if you get covet have a
much milder version of covid
overall the shot is said to be 66
effective this preliminary data comes
from a trial involving 44
000 people in the united states latin
america
and south africa as we're talking about
supply chain issues and running out of
vaccine and
all this stuff you know 66 percent after
a single dose
is still really really really good other
vaccines such as pfizer biontec and
moderna
are said to be more than 90 percent
effective
astrazeneca comes in at around 62
percent
it like johnson and johnson shot is dna
based
it still targets the viruses spike
protein teaching the body to recognize
it
and produce antibodies however it uses a
non-active flu-like virus as the
delivery system
johnson johnson says when it comes to
severe illness and death
the shot performs even better we got 85
protection against severe disease 100
protection
for debt and 100 protection for
hospitalization
protection is what everyone is looking
for
this week novavax also added a piece to
the protective puzzle
saying data from its phase 3 uk trial
found its
two-dose vaccine to be 89.3 percent
effective
adding it does provide protection for
both the uk
and south african variants the world
health organization
and many national regulators say a
minimum efficacy rate of 50 percent is
needed before vaccines should be
considered for authorization
like all vaccines we have to actually
get that data reviewed many vaccines we
would love to have more of them but we
don't have
them right now the drug companies will
now turn their attention to seeking
emergency use
approval in different countries crystal
gomansing global news
london the prime minister also confirmed
that provinces and territories will now
receive the other one billion dollars in
back to school funding
that was promised last summer this
1 billion dollar investment will go
towards everything from more sanitizer
to better ventilation for classrooms to
support for online learning
and remote classes last august the
federal government committed up to 2
billion dollars for the safe return to
class fund
the first installment was paid last fall
when schools reopened
across the country as the pandemic drags
on more canadians are struggling to pay
the rent
advocates say we've long had an
affordable housing problem in this
country
and as far nasser explains on top of
this health emergency
there's an unprecedented eviction crisis
as well
it has been a devastating year for
zenith jahan
her husband passed away of cancer last
january
and then came the pandemic
i lost my husband lost the major part of
income lost my job
suddenly she says she was struggling to
pay the bills and she now owes 8
thousand dollars in back rent
in may she got an eviction notice from
her landlord pinedale properties
i'm feeling the fear of homelessness
pinedale claims they've reached
repayment agreements with the majority
of tenants who are struggling
and they haven't evicted anyone during
the pandemic they also told global news
they offered jahan a repayment plan
but she didn't respond it would have
required her to pay 900 dollars a month
for 10 months
on top of her 1500 dollar rent an amount
she says
she can't afford so her eviction notice
is still pending
most provinces temporarily paused
evictions during the first wave
but by the end of summer those bans were
lifted
and in ontario that led to a surge of
online eviction hearings
7 thousand of them in november alone i
observed tenants being
evicted in as little as 60
90 seconds public health experts say the
virus has exposed
long-existing housing issues to say that
we're going to have a whole new
generation
of people move into chronic homelessness
i mean that's even more of a damning
failure at the height of the first wave
in may
a record 2.6 million canadians were
unemployed
or 13.7 percent by july
the overall unemployment rate had
dropped to 9.3 percent
but in racialized communities it was
nearly double that figure
we are not all together in this crisis
regions are becoming rich poorer
becoming more
poor we've been told for months stay
home and stay safe
that's easy to say but without more
financial support for renters
it's much harder to do especially for
those facing eviction
faran asser global news toronto
toronto's fire chief calls it an
unspeakable tragedy
early this morning a fire ripped through
a home killing four people
fire crews were called to the home early
this morning it took three hours before
the flames were brought under control
six people were pulled from the
residence two were rushed to hospital
one remains in critical condition the
other person
is stable these are hard days
they're hard days for our team they're
hard days for our city
this is one of the most one of the one
of the worst tragedies by fire i've seen
in my career
the flames jumped to two other homes but
no one in the neighboring houses was
hurt
several firefighters however were
injured at one point there was a mayday
call for a firefighter
thought to be trapped but he managed to
get out investigators have not
determined
what caused the fire betting against the
big boys coming up the turmoil on wall
street as small investors rally
against major hedge funds
in the u.s federal officials are
reviewing gamestop's
unbelievable stock surge 8 thousand
percent in the past six months
it all began when hedge funds started
shorting stocks in the struggling video
game retailer
betting its stock price would drop and
they'd make money but online investors
began
gobbling it up making millions jennifer
johnson has the latest
wall street's top cop the securities and
exchange commission
is taking a hard look at what unfolded
after reddit's wall street bets
community
outsmarted big name hedge funds by
driving up gamestop's
stock the hedge funds bet the struggling
video game companies worth would
continue to tank
but amateurs went online and drove it up
it's not investing and as long as they
look
at it as speculation there's no problem
at all
it's not dissimilar to buying a lottery
ticket
in a sense you have to be a little bit
lucky but the luck ran out quickly after
robin hood
a popular app among armchair investors
pulled the plug
and stopped more people from buying
gamestop stock
the sec is reviewing why it's
infuriating
they're basically saying we'll let the
big boys keep playing but the little
guys have to sit this one out now
some believe robin hood was trying to
protect the hedge funds that were losing
billions
robin hood also restricted trading on
blackberry and bed bath and beyond
many lawmakers were furious all of a
sudden the billionaires and some hedge
funds
are yelling because they're not the ones
the only ones
who make money when the manipulation
works the head of robin hood
denies any wrongdoing we absolutely did
not do
this at the direction of any market
maker
or hedge fund or anyone we route to or
other market participants
some small investors made big bucks in
the revolt trying to get rich quick
others say they just wanted to stick it
to wall street elites this is a chance
to get the
five five five and they got enough
people we don't fully understand all the
intentions right now
experts are warning this kind of buying
is risky because any stock can drop
dramatically in a matter of seconds
but some young investors didn't seem to
care it's the regular joe's versus wall
street
and that's what when i put money into it
i said even if this goes to zero and i
lose everything
i like being a part of it whether the
stock surge will help gamestop survive
this pandemic is unknown
but its three biggest individual
shareholders are now billionaires
jennifer johnson global news washington
and a ten-year-old boy from texas has
cashed in from gamestop
two years ago jayden carr's mother
bought him 10 shares to teach her son
about economics
she paid 60 u.s at the time well this
budding broker has learned a thing or
two and he sold his stock
for 3 200 american
still ahead general motors electric
shift and how it will drive canada's
auto industry
automakers have long been told the only
way to drive the industry forward
is to reverse emissions and phase out
fossil fuels for more environmentally
sustainable options
general motors is aiming to go all
electric the company will end the
production of gas and diesel-powered
cars and trucks by 2035
and turn completely carbon neutral by
2040.
as eric sorensen reports the shift is
impacting canada's
auto manufacturing industry
for more than a hundred years fossil
fuels have been the lifeblood of the
combustion engines built by general
motors
but in a world of undeniable climate
change pressure to choke off tail pipe
emissions
that cause greenhouse gases is turning
gm
green most of its cars will be electric
vehicles by 2035.
it comes on top of gm's plans to invest
about 35 billion dollars in electric
and autonomous vehicles over the next
five years
gm ceo calls the historic moment an
inflection point
the moment when our world's reliance on
gas and diesel-powered vehicles
will begin transitioning to an
all-electric future
e-vehicles represent just 3 percent of
the world's vehicle market
but gm's move could spur a chain
reaction of industries to turn greener
faster it's going to have all kinds of
impacts along
not just general motors and its massive
supply chain but in terms of moving the
whole
goal posts towards a ev future and a
carbon neutral future
the old expression what's good for gm is
good for the country
may now be what's good for the planet
electric vehicles
represent an important climate solution
but also an important economic solution
when you look at major auto
manufacturers such as dm
making commitments to have zero tailpipe
emissions by 2035
that's significant in canada gm is
undertaking a billion dollar
transformation of this ontario plant
from producing the gas drinking equinox
to new electric delivery vehicles for
companies like fedex that's where the
industry is heading
that's where consumers are heading
they're not there today but they will be
and canada also sees it as an incredible
opportunity to create jobs
but among the cascading effects of gm
changing gears
is potentially another blow to canada's
oil and gas economy
large fossil fuel producing provinces
the writing is on the wall
and they need to start thinking about
how they're going to transition out of
the
oil economy gm plans to release 30 new
e-vehicles by 2025
and that still leaves room to go big in
car buying an e-powered humvee
is coming out in the next year eric
sorensen global news toronto
the model turned role model for
generations of black women
up next the remarkable life of cicely
tyson
he'll know when to call me
when they call me i'll be ready
hollywood legend
cicely tyson has died tyson got her
start as a model
that helped launch a television movie
and broadway career spanning more than
six decades
she became one of the first black actors
in a recurring tv
role in east side west side
her role as the sharecropper's wife and
sounder earned her an oscar nomination
she won two emmys for the 1974
television
drama the autobiography of miss jane
pittman
a new generation of moviegoers witnessed
her talent in the hit
the help in 2013 she won a tony award
at the age of 88. tyson helped shatter
hollywood's stereotypes by insisting she
played characters
that allowed her to radiate dignity and
strength
in 2016 she was given the presidential
medal of freedom
the highest civilian honor in the united
states
and just this week she released a memoir
called just as i am
tyson was 96.
across the country canadians are marking
a somber anniversary it has been four
years since the deadly shooting at a
mosque in quebec city
most of today's memorials are taking
place online
including the green square campaign
supporters wear a green square
representing the green carpets at the
mosque
as a display of unity on this day in
2017
six men were killed when a gunman opened
fire at the quebec city islamic cultural
center
it remains the worst mass murder in a
house of worship in canadian history
tonight we leave you with more of the
touching tributes to the victims
good night
you